RICH HYNDMAN: Hi there and
welcome to this week's Android
Developer Office Hours.
One day late, but brought to
you from the usual place in
our studio in London.
Today I'm Richard Hyndman, I'm
always Richard Hyndman, and
I'm joined by,
STEPHAN LINZNER: Stephan
Linzner.
CHRIS BANES: Chris Banes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: So the reason
that this is a day late is
because Chris is just
running a bit slow.
That's fine.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: As normal, we
won't be discussing roadmap
stuff that's not been
preannounced, but we will be
talking about Android
development topics.
Thank you to all the people
in the Hangout
that joined us today.
That's quite a quick
introduction.
CHRIS BANES: No one.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh no, there we
go, someone's joined us.
We are now officially live.
We have a viewer.
NICK BUTCHER: But as usual we
are prioritizing questions
asked in the moderator
beforehand.
RICH HYNDMAN: There's Andrew
Kelly just to watch all these
questions come through.
Some of the things that have
happened this week, Mobile
World Congress was
on this week.
Over in Barcelona.
HTC announced the One.
CHRIS BANES: Very nice
looking device it is.
RICH HYNDMAN: It means the HTC
One X is now the X HTC One,
and the HTC One is
the new HTC One?
No, OK, that doesn't work.
NICK BUTCHER: Pivot on.
RICH HYNDMAN: But it
does look nice.
Previously, I'd heard about
five-inch 1080p screens and
thought maybe it was
a bit much, but a
4.7 inch 1080p screen.
I really trust HDC for their
screen quality as well, from
the One X and other devices.
Their screens are
pretty awesome.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, their device
quality, the hardware
quality's always
been very good.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh my god,
someone's discovered metal as
well, haven't they?
It's an Android manufacturer
making a device out of metal.
And so I'm quite excited to go
see the HTC One at some point.
I haven't got my hands
on one yet.
Anyone know the shipping date?
STEPHAN LINZNER: No.
NICK BUTCHER: March sometime.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, it's soon.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm quite
looking forward to
seeing one of those.
That will be kind of cool.
NICK BUTCHER: Add a whole load
of five-inch 1080p things.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN:Yeah, plenty of
five-inch 1080p things.
Which I'm sure some screen
manufacturer's doing trade.
You can trade in those.
Google Play Services.
We had an update to
that this week.
Major update to Google
Play Services.
Now we have your Google+
Sign-In.
Anyone had a chance to
look through the
Google+ Sign-In stuff?
No?
I've seen the Google Play
services demo from the +Team
that they're doing.
It seems pretty simple.
You can just request the
authentication details, and it
comes up with a nice white
dialog saying, this user would
like access to your whatever.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: You guys put it
on your website saying,
install the app.
Be like one click right
from your website.
I think that's pretty--
RICH HYNDMAN: That is really
nice, that button that we have
in Play Store, the
install button.
If they're logged in--
is it if they're logged
in to Google+?
If they're logged
in to Chrome?
Just Google+?
NICK BUTCHER: If you've
got a session open.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you've
That install button will work on
your website, and you just
have to-- boom--
straight on to the
Android device.
That is kind of cool.
And I've seen a lot
of those around.
NICK BUTCHER: The deep linking
is quite cool as well.
So you can share links to
specific parts within the
application.
Which is pretty cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: And Maps
got updates as well.
Maps v2 got some updates
as well.
Maybe fixes--
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
bug fixes.--
RICH HYNDMAN: There's a list of
those changes available via
+AndroidDevelopers.
Anything else at pre-show?
CHRIS BANES: Nick's sporting
a new device.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh yeah, this is
now the Chrome Office Hours,
brought to you by Nick
and his Pixel.
Nick's single Pixel.
Woo, look at that.
NICK BUTCHER: It's very nice.
It's a nice Chromebook.
Amazing screen.
Incredible screen.
To get it light though, you
have to close it and
everything and make it open.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Fantastic.
Andrew Case's [? evening? ?]
Unless anyone in the Hangout has
a question for us, we'll
dive straight into
that moderator.
Four people got in.
STEPHAN LINZNER: There was a
question on the uiautomator
where somebody is having
a part problem.
When he calls the message says,
"horizontal list." On
4.1, actually I think this
should not happen, but please
provide us with more
information.
Maybe your manifest,
maybe some code.
We need more information
to come back at you.
It looks like it should
work on 4.0 and 4.2.
RICH HYNDMAN: Huh.
Has anyone used uiautomator
yet?
CHRIS BANES: I don't know.
It's on my to-do list.
STEPHAN LINZNER: I've played
around with it a little bit.
It's actually quite nice.
But I think this should
really work on 4.1.
I don't see why there should be
a restriction on 4.1 when
it's working on 4.2.
Send us more information, and
we'll try to help you.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
raise a bug on b.android.com.
RICH HYNDMAN: Tools.android.com?
CHRIS BANES: I guess,
try that.
And yeah, [INAUDIBLE] going
to help you on there.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Sorry.
So--
STEPHAN LINZNER: We have another
question regarding how
you can identify your users.
There actually was a blog
post from Tim Bray
like one year ago.
I think you're good off if
you're just going in there and
looking at what he suggests.
Basically what he's saying
is to create a UUID.
When you install the
application, just basically
create a UUID and maintain
this UUID.
Of course, you will also see
that he will refer to using
things like you mentioned.
Like secure Android ID, and the
calling gets a device ID,
and other things, but those
have major drawbacks.
But just look at the post, and I
think you will find the best
solution for your requirement.
RICH HYNDMAN: If people wonder
why I keep looking down and
typing away again, we're
indexing this week's show
again, so I'm just putting
a little note
next to each question.
So in the YouTube comments later
on, the YouTube video
makes more sense.
People can flip through to the
most appropriate part.
CHRIS BANES: So you got a
question from Kite Surfer, who
asks, how can I install
an image view
globally from his theme?
His application theme.
"My designer wants these margins
everywhere, how do I
do this easily?"
Well, there's no sort
of built-in,
standard way to do this.
Not like ListView which has
ListView style in it's--
the global theme.
So you're going to have to do
it yourself, basically.
So you can either create a style
and then reference that
style in [? XML. ?]
A quick way I thought of doing
it was to create a custom
issue and then overload the
constructor to always pass in
your style.
That's probably the quickest way
of doing it, but there's
no built-in framework way.
RICH HYNDMAN: So if you wanted
one style of imagery across
your whole application, it makes
a lot of sense to have
you write apps.
STEPHAN LINZNER: But there is no
definition in a theme, and
you cannot refer to [? repair ?]
in that field.
So you have to do it like
Chris just suggested.
RICH HYNDMAN: Indeed.
If you go all the way and then
have some custom attributes
inside your [INAUDIBLE]
passing.
CHRIS BANES: You could do.
You wrote a blog post
about that.
RICH HYNDMAN: I wrote a blog
post about it quite recently,
last week, yeah.
So just check
geekyouup.blogspot.com for
more information.
Or +richhyndman.
We've had some more
people join us in
the chat since then.
We've got a dog, and Giuseppe.
Hey guys, how you doing?
GIUSEPPE: Hi guys,
not too bad.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thank you for
joining us one day late.
Our apologies for the staffing
issues that led to this not
being on yesterday.
Who's the dog there as well?
GIUSEPPE: Guys, I have two
technical questions.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
GIUSEPPE: Well, the first one
is that in my Eclipse IDE
disappeared from the Google
menu add native support.
Anyone have experience
with that?
CHRIS BANES: Repeat
the last bit.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: Add
native support?
GIUSEPPE: Using the
ADT of Android in
Eclipse, you have a menu.
When you click right under your
projects, then you have
an Android menu, and then there
is add native support.
From my menu this
has disappeared.
I don't have it any more.
For a few projects,
not for every one.
RICH HYNDMAN: Really?
Well, I don't have a coding
machine site with me here
unfortunately.
CHRIS BANES: I didn't even know
what the native support
option did.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, there is native
support that add for
you the C++ support.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BANES: I wonder if that
only happens if you've got the
C++ extension installed
in Eclipse?
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, everything
is [INAUDIBLE]
version 21 revision 2,
everything works well.
I have many applications with
the native support.
But something needs a 21 update,
that Tor released last
week, then there is
this problem.
Just asking if someone has the
same problem, if there is not,
I will find it myself.
Or I will write some email
to Tor directly.
RICH HYNDMAN: Sure.
Yossi, can you replicate
that same
issue just out of interest?
YOSSI: I just checked it.
Did you set the indicate
path for the Eclipse?
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, everything.
YOSSI: It's just disappeared?
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, it's
disappeared.
Just disappeared
from the menu.
Disappeared just for
a few projects.
For example, in my left side I
have 20 projects 10 of them, I
have this menu, and other
10, there is none.
Very strange.
And I don't know why, starting
with this update, the
StrictMode starts to throw a
strange exception on SQL
Database open.
Saying that the database is open
when this is not true.
If you're out of the StrictMode,
and then you try
to close your cursor, then the
database, and then the
connection, you will see
that the StrictMode
will throw an exception.
This didn't happen before.
YOSSI: To the second issue,
you're using begin transaction
and end transaction?
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
YOSSI: On all the database
methods?
GIUSEPPE: No.
CHRIS BANES: The StrictMode
is in framework isn't it?
So that would be to do with
your device [INAUDIBLE].
GIUSEPPE: Let me confirm again
that this happened only
starting the revision
21 of the ADT.
On the 20, this didn't happen.
RICH HYNDMAN: This shouldn't
be part of ADT where the
StrictMode is.
GIUSEPPE: Nothing to do with
the StrictMode, I know.
RICH HYNDMAN: Are you having the
issue on all devices that
you test it on, or just
one or two devices?
GIUSEPPE: No, all devices.
If I open a simple connection,
then I open the cursor.
I redo the cursor, close the
cursor, close the connection,
close the database, and then
change the activity, and then
this throws the exception.
Very simple code, a few lines.
RICH HYNDMAN: How much
exception is it?
GIUSEPPE: It says, you are
closing an activity that has
an open connection with
database, or something like
that approximately.
YOSSI: Have you tried
using CursorLoader?
GIUSEPPE: No.
I didn't try.
I just tried with the
standard mode.
Just opened the cursor just
using a simple SQL helper.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: I wonder how
StrictMode is tracking that,
whether it's waiting for the
garbage collection to clear up
the database before it realizes
that the activity no
longer has it open.
I don't know what StrictMode
is using.
GIUSEPPE: The problem of the
garbage collector was when you
use the provider.
When you use the provider to
connect to the database, then
you don't have to close any
cursor because the provider
takes charge of closing
everything.
But in the case of a simple
code, you open the connection,
you open the cursor, you close
it, and then why is the
StrictMode is throwing
this exception?
It's very strange.
RICH HYNDMAN: There's
no other--
GIUSEPPE: In the Android 2.3,
this didn't happen.
Starting in Android 4.2,
this happened.
I didn't try to do
it in Ice Cream.
I would try it later,
but [INAUDIBLE]
Gingerbread, no.
RICH HYNDMAN: Who's off line?
Is it Giuseppe or us?
YOSSI: I'm thinking Giuseppe.
No?
He's online.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: Not this
time, interesting.
GIUSEPPE: That was the
first question.
And then there is also
a second question.
Is there any way to use a
downloaded native library and
load it from a simple folder
and not from a data folder?
RICH HYNDMAN: Not
that I know of.
You can check Stack Overflow
for that one.
STEPHAN LINZNER: There
is a DexClassLoader.
So you can fetch a .jar,
and you can--
GIUSEPPE: With the
DexClassLoader, I can load
Java library.
I am talking about .so library,
native library.
RICH HYNDMAN: I know what you're
trying to do inside
your application.
I don't know a way
of doing it.
CHRIS BANES: You could use
another Android application
with the same user ID.
And then the user would have
to install the extra--
GIUSEPPE: I would like to ask
if you can repeat the answer
because I lost the connection.
CHRIS BANES: So this
is how most video
players work on the market.
You have the video player and
then other sort of plug-ins
you can install which give you
CPU-specific binaries.
So you can create another
application.
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, but the user
will have two applications.
In that case, this
is a solution.
But to use this, my
application and
my application codec?
Codec one, codec two.
It's not very good
for the user.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, but the other
side of it's quite a bit
of a security hole if you
can just download--
execute--
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, because
I think that--
CHRIS BANES: I can't think
of a way to do it,
and I doubt you can.
NICK BUTCHER: You can't just
download and open it?
RICH HYNDMAN: Not from the data
directory apparently.
Not if it wasn't bundled
inside the application.
GIUSEPPE: Because there is one
of our applications that uses
some codec for special things.
But not all of the
users need it.
The codec [? weight ?]
is upwards 10
megabytes for each processor.
So if I wanted to take care of
everybody, everybody must have
an application larger
than 50 megabytes,
and that's not good.
So if you needed a function,
then you download the codec.
But I was finding some
way to download a new
package, a new IPK.
Just looking if I can download
myself, unzip the file, and
then load using the system
load for example.
But I tried it myself.
There is no way because
say that
prompted for no execution.
Correct?
RICH HYNDMAN: Correct.
CHRIS BANES: Because the thing
is when you install the
application and the framework
just doesn't--
I can't remember
specifically--
but links against the
system libraries.
And it does lots of specific
stuff with that.
So if the libraries you're
linked against, the ones that
run the device, it will
do some special stuff.
I can't remember
the specifics.
So it's all tied in to install
applications, so the framework
needs to do stuff.
So you can't really just
download library space.
GIUSEPPE: You know what
personally, this is in my
opinion, and then later I leave
the space and allow
other people to speak?
My opinion is that it's very
bad to see that application
that uses a root system.
They are able to write
in the data folder.
They are able to load from the
data folder of this library.
They have concept logic better
than an application that
doesn't use the root.
RICH HYNDMAN: Of course.
There's a lot of things that
root access would make it a
lot easier for you.
But it's a worse security
hole OK.
We don't actually have
answers for those
questions right now though.
I'm sorry, Giuseppe.
Hopefully when you ping the
Tools Team, you'll find out
some of the answers.
CHRIS BANES: There's
quite a lot of chat
going on in the window.
RICH HYNDMAN: There is.
I can't read any of the
chat in the window.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: So have we got
another question from the
moderator we can jump into?
And then I'll take one from
the G+ Stream after that.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: Lyndon just asked
in the comments, Lyndon
Darling asks, how does he get
into the pure Android?
So that's generally as a result
of going through the
App Clinic and Android Designer
Action process.
So [INAUDIBLE]
is the way to go there.
Do suggest new topics if your
app doesn't fall into one of
the topics.
Or if it does fall into one of
the topics already suggested,
then make it clear that you are
the developer, and you're
self nominating, because we
do totally prefer those.
I think the bitly link is broken
so you can't go to
bit.ly/appclinic.
If you just Google for Android
App Clinic, try to
fix it at first hit.
RICH HYNDMAN: I might have
to do that myself.
I want to be pure Android.
I'm straining to read that
bar at the side.
Actually, talking about that,
someone's put in the comments,
they would like to know why we
went from a surface view to a
custom view on the Ultimate
Stopwatch and what the
performance benefits were
and why we did it.
Generally the surface views on
Android have always been a
hole punched through your UI
layers and then rendered on
the very top as a canvas.
They've never been hardware
accelerated.
So if you were using surface
views, you got a lot of
flexibility, but you missed out
on all the hotness that
was introduced with the hardware
acceleration 3, 3.4,
4.1, and 4.2.
It actually didn't
take long at all.
I'd been putting it off for
ages, but it didn't take long
at all to convert from a surface
view to a custom view.
And now I've done a whole load
of benchmarking on it, and
frame redraws have gone down
from like 45 miliseconds to
one millisecond now.
So there's other things
in the way.
I'm using the Vsync
as suggested by--
was it Sue who chimed in saying
I should use Vsync?
I think it was.
So it's limiting it at 60 frames
a second, and it easily
manages it with the hardware
acceleration But even on non
hardware accelerated devices,
because a whole load of new
tools become available to you
once you're doing hardware
accelerated rendering.
The GPU profiling tools and
that sort of thing have
managed to optimize it
so it's a lot faster.
Even as a custom view on
Gingerbread than it was on--
NICK BUTCHER: Do
you use Tracer?
Or OpenGL ES?
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm not
using OpenGL.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: No I just use
the tools inside developer
options on here.
Turning on overdraws and
that sort of thing.
And CPU profiling
and overdraws.
And it turned out that I had
a white background on my
[? Geo Pager ?] that was being
drawn every frame, which you
couldn't see, and there was
another white background
somewhere else that was being
drawn every frame.
I took a few of those out, and
it halved the original times.
Everything turned green.
STEPHAN LINZNER: I think it's
very helpful to use those
tools because you can
easily optimize.
Because sometimes it's just
a low-hanging fruit.
RICH HYNDMAN: See with that you
have to read through every
single line of code trying
to optimize it,
which can be a pain.
NICK BUTCHER: In the comment
thread, Jamie Hybod asks, if
he has an app that is
distributed via email, will
his stats appear in the
Developer Console
for ANRs and so forth?
I don't think it will, right?
I think if you have that package
name reserved on the
Developer Console, you will
still get it, no matter where
they install it from.
But you have to have
it on the Developer
Console first, right?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah if there's
a list in flat package.
NICK BUTCHER: Back
to the moderator.
RICH HYNDMAN: Where
did you see that?
Was it on the G+ thread?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Those were on the comments
on the Hangout thread.
Do we have any moderator
questions we're ready for?
Using Maps fragments inside of
a ViewPager causes black
rectangles to be left when
paging, a bit like shearing.
Any tips to avoid this?
CHRIS BANES: It's the same
thing as what Rich was on
about earlier.
And Maps actually uses
surface view.
So again, it's a sort of view
punched through the back of
the window.
There isn't really many
tips you can do.
You can kind of display a view
over the top and kind of block
the flash so it's not
so visually obvious.
Other than that, it's just the
way it is kind of thing.
If you're having a map view in
a ViewPager, you've got two
horizontally scrolling items
anyway, so I'd be careful.
There's not much you can do.
You can hide it, but you
can't really fix it.
There's a question in
the chat, actually.
Claudio has asked, "Do you have
any examples of doing
facial recognition?"
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
We have a facial recognition
sample somewhere.
It pulls out eyes, nose,
mouth stuff.
To find facial recognition
actually, it will tell you
that there's faces in the
picture and how many faces and
where the various points
on those faces are.
What it won't do is say that
it's Chris Banes, or Stephan
Linzner, or whatever.
You have to do that bit
with your own eyes.
So by facial recognitions, you
mean the fact that there's
faces there, or actually
who the faces are?
"Face recognition" or "facial
recognition" is how--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: Probably
the latter, in
which case no, I don't.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BANES: The class is
called face detector.
But there are a few caveats
to it in that it
only supports bitmaps.
And it only supports bitmaps
in the format RGB565.
It does not support 888s.
RICH HYNDMAN: It doesn't
do the 888s?
CHRIS BANES: No, it's
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: There you go.
Now just wait to see if someone
puts that in the
comments thread.
"Is the MapView, is scroll
locked first--" can't you zoom
in on this thing on the side?
NICK BUTCHER: Command plus.
RICH HYNDMAN: There we go.
That was easy.
"I see the icon with the Android
SDK management, when I
click it, nothing happens."
Open up a command window
depending on if you're
on Mac or PC.
Open up a command or a command
shell and run it and see
what's the exception
that's coming up.
OK, on a Map, just open up your
shell, find your SDK, and
go into the tools directory,
and run Android, and you'll
see the exception that's
coming out while
this is being run.
You probably can't find Java
or something crazy.
No exception?
Nothing happens at all?
Buy a new Mac?
MALE SPEAKER: Can you
guys hear me?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: No, actually
it runs.
So when I run it, the monitor
comes up, but I only see the
device tab.
So when you run up the monitor,
you can look and see
the device tab.
But then there should be also
a device about the different
Android SDKs that
you can install.
NICK BUTCHER: It sounds like
you're running a device
monitor, not the Android.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, so I'm just
running the wrong monitor.
NICK BUTCHER: There's an
executable just called
Android, and you just
need to run that.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So I'll launch that
from the terminal.
Thanks.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, try that.
If that doesn't work, then
make sure you've got the
latest version of the
ADT tools as well.
You can download it packaged
up or not.
You'll need the latest version
for Jelly Bean devices anyway.
We've had that question
a few times.
You'll plug the Jelly Bean
device into your computer, and
you run ADB, and it says it's
offline, that's because you
need the latest version
of ADT tools where the
secure ADB is included.
And the next time you run ADB
devices you'll see on your
screen, it says, "Will you allow
debugging from this hex
code computer?" And when you say
yes, then it switches from
offline to online.
So if you do see that in ADB,
just make sure you've got the
latest tools from
tools.android.com.
MALE SPEAKER: Perfect, thanks.
CHRIS BANES: Claudio has put, "I
can detect a face, but not
which store information for
facial recognition." So you're
trying to detect individual
faces?
As in people rather
than faces?
Face Set detects eyes.
That's the main thing
it detects.
RICH HYNDMAN: Very handy
for putting glasses
on pictures of people.
"I detect a face but not which
store information for face
recognition." Sorry, I still
don't understand, Claudio.
One more shot at elaborating,
we'll have another go.
CHRIS BANES: There's a few
online services that offer
APIs that you can do
that kind of stuff.
Face.com is one off the
top of my head.
NICK BUTCHER: What
about Facebook?
CHRIS BANES: That's for what
Andrew Kelly's all about.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Last three minutes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: "Any thoughts
about the background drawable
defining the minimum size
of views?" Is that
what you want to happen?
No.
But you could put an imagery
inside a layout and then wrap
everything to that content.
And at least the whole layout
would be minimum size of the
image, and then you
could import that
into another layout.
If you wanted to lay out
a hierarchy madness.
CHRIS BANES: Is he trying to say
that he doesn't want it to
be minimum size?
RICH HYNDMAN: Or of course you
can use min width and min
height on the view and just give
it the number of DPs or
even pixels of the images, if
you really wanted to do that.
Schedule, "This Hangout
is great.
Does it happen every week?" Yes,
it happens every week on
Wednesdays, except when
it's on Thursdays.
But that's quite rare.
It's always on Wednesdays.
YOSSI: Can I have a
quick question?
Yossi, of course.
YOSSI: What do you think
about implementing?
I have a list of items
that I have.
I want to show the user a couple
of quick actions on the
same row for each item, but I
need to have two more actions
to each item on the list.
So basically I have four
actions, but two of them
should be quick actions, so
I'll do a custom view with
added buttons or something?
And what do you think should be
the implementation or the
UI for having an interaction
for two more actions?
I thought about the long press,
but I'm not sure that's
proper, because I have
actions on the view.
What's your suggestion?
NICK BUTCHER: You could do
contextual by a long press,
contextual action bar.
But just don't do a
pop-up dialogue
is what I was thinking.
Or an alternative, if you can
look at something like the
cards in Google Now, they have
like a small version of the
overflow button which leads
to additional actions.
Or I was talking about the music
app at this [INAUDIBLE]
seminar where they drop down
their little disclosure arrow
which you could normally
use for spinners.
You could do that to
show a pop-up menu.
That could work as well.
YOSSI: The overflow button from
Google Now could be on
each item on the list?
NICK BUTCHER:Yep.
Or the disclosure
triangle thing.
CHRIS BANES: I prefer
the triangle.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
me too actually.
The thing about the contextual
action bar is that if it is
contextual actions, I mean
that's what it's there for.
And also it means if you can
perform the action on multiple
items, you kind of get that
behavior for free with the
contextual bar imitation,
which I really like.
YOSSI: Yeah.
And that's what I thought
because I'm trying to merge
several actions to
be more specific.
I wanted to use the speed
action bar to show quick
actions that are changing
contextually when you long
hold and when you don't have
the long press edit mode.
And I wasn't sure if I can maybe
show that button, or
should I use the contextual
menu?
I thought of a lot
of suggestions.
I wasn't sure which
ones to implement.
NICK BUTCHER: I like some kind
of contextual action bar, or
some kind of drop-down
with [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BANES: Just don't do
a single click to open
contextual action bar.
That's horrible.
YOSSI: No, no, no.
Wouldn't do it no matter what.
RICH HYNDMAN: Nick did clarify
that he actually wanted the
background image not to specify
the minimum size.
So if you got a 100X20 text
view, and the image is
100X100, the text
view will grow.
You could use 9-patch images,
something like that, or your
own custom version
of text view.
I would say go with the
9-patch if you can.
And then just define the scaling
areas and the content
areas so that you actually have
some consistency over
what the background
image will be.
Otherwise you're not
going to know.
I mean the system's not just
going to make a guess at which
part of the image you
want the shot.
Also, quick shout out
to the Berlin GDG.
Why not?
If you're an Android developer
and you want some help
locally, then go to your local
Google Developer Group.
Because they all have
similar interests.
And there's a London Android
user group here.
In Berlin, there's
the Berlin GDG.
They're all over the place,
and you can find them by
searching for GDGs on Google.
Anything else before
we finish?
YOSSI: Yeah.
Are you coming next week to
the convention in Israel?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
Nick and I might be in
Israel for Monday and
Tuesday next week.
See you there.
You'll be there?
YOSSI: Yeah, I am lecturing.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right.
I'll share the podium
with you.
Thanks everyone.
We'll catch you again
next week.
YOSSI: See you guys.
MALE SPEAKER: All
right, thanks.
STEPHAN LINZNER: Bye-bye.